he calls this maximum pressure Donald
Trump has hit Iran with a new wave of
sanctions he's going for the very top of
the regime sanctions imposed through the
executive order that I'm about to sign
will deny the Supreme Leader in the
Supreme Leader's office and those
closely affiliated with him and the
office access to key financial resources
and support the assets of Ayatollah
Khomeini and his office will not be
spared from the sanctions President
Trump wants a new deal with Iran in
return for sanctions relief it's not
just about nuclear weapons he also wants
to Iran to stop supporting proxy
militias and curb its missile program
but Iran's showing no sign of cracking
under the US pressure in Iran today
Mindy Kaling is there any sanction left
for America to impose that has not been
imposed on us recently or in the last 40
years and is there anything that they
have gained from this in fact president
Trump's policy could backfire well we
have seen over the past few weeks as a
consequence of sanction indicate that
sanction and maximum pressure are more
likely to push the two sides into a
confrontation direct or indirect and
rather than into a potential
de-escalation between the two sides it's
not just sanctions on Washington's mind
America's top diplomat is met with
smiles on a visit to Saudi Arabia and
Abu Dhabi he's seeking to build a force
to protect shipping lanes here as the
crisis with Iran deepens the concern
follows attacks on tankers near the
Strait of Hormuz the u.s. blames Iran
though Tehran denies involvement here in
the United Arab Emirates there's a
strong desire for the crisis to be
resolved peacefully this country has the
largest port in the Middle East and a
vibrant maritime industry they'd be hit
hard should the tensions between the
u.s. and Iran flare up into war tonight
of fragile calm is holding but the next
few days are seen as critical as to
which way this standoff goes
Debra Haines Sky News Abu Dhabi